T-15 seconds. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. T-1910, 9 or 8? On January 28, 1986, the Challenger spacecraft blasted off from Cape Canaveral in Florida. One and liftoff. Liftoff solved the 25th space shuttle mission and it has cleared the tower. Seconds after liftoff into a clear blue sky. Something went wrong. Like a trodder's here looking very carefully at the situation.
倒计时15秒。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。T-1910，9还是8？1986年1月28日，挑战者号航天飞机从佛罗里达州的卡纳维拉尔角腾空而起。1秒，点火升空。点火升空标志着第25次航天飞机任务开始，它已经飞离了发射塔。在升空几秒钟后，进入了一片晴朗的蓝天。出事了。就像这里的特罗德（Trodd)在非常仔细地观察情况一样。
Obviously a major malfunction. It was much more than a malfunction. It was a disaster. As millions of people watched in horror, trails of smoke and debris flew off in different directions. We have a report from the flight dynamics officer that the vehicle has exploded. What appears to be a major catastrophe in America's space program, Challenger only seconds after leaving the launch pad, according to NASA, has exploded in mid-air. exploded in mid-air.
显然是发生了重大故障。这不仅仅是故障。这是一场灾难。正当数百万人惊恐地注视着时，缕缕浓烟和碎片朝不同方向飞去。我们从飞行动力学官员那里得到报告称，飞行器已经爆炸。据美国宇航局称，这似乎是美国太空计划中的一场重大灾难，挑战者号在离开发射台仅几秒钟后，在空中发生了爆炸。在空中发生了爆炸。
After the explosion, NASA officials were hauled to Capitol Hill and put to questioning. Who finally made that decision to go? What was the chain? How did that link? What happened then specifically? Members of Congress asked the tough questions. How could this have happened? Who's to blame? Were they warning signs that were ignored? These are the kinds of questions we have when any catastrophe occurs, whether a spacecraft has exploded
爆炸发生后，美国宇航局官员被传讯到国会山接受质询。究竟是谁做出发射决定的？决策链是怎样的？各个环节是如何联系的？当时具体发生了什么？国会议员们提出了尖锐的问题。这怎么可能发生？谁该承担责任？难道有什么警告信号被忽视了吗？每当灾难发生时，无论是航天器爆炸
or a city's been attacked by terrorists. In all these cases, we want to know, who's screwed up? Your government failed you. Those entrusted with protecting you, failed you. And I failed you. We ask who knew what? When? The State Department had received repeated warnings
还是城市遭到恐怖袭击，我们都会产生这类疑问。在所有这些情况下，我们都想知道：究竟是谁搞砸了？你们的政府让你们失望了。那些受托保护你们的人，让你们失望了。而我也让你们失望了。我们会问：谁知道什么？什么时候知道的？国务院曾多次接到警告
that the situation was getting worse. And we try to figure out how. How do we make sure that this kind of breach that such an accident never happened again? how? That this kind of breach does not happen again. With many of these incidents, there's a sense that they could have been avoided, that someone knew something but didn't say anything, or if they said it, they weren't believed, or if they were believed, nothing was done. This week on Hidden Brain, the psychology of warnings, why some warnings get heard, why many are ignored, and the pitfalls of being a prophet.
称情况正在恶化。我们试图找出方法。我们如何确保这种违规行为、这种事故永远不再发生？怎么做？确保这种违规行为不再发生。对于其中许多事件，人们总觉得它们本可以避免，有人知道某些内情却秘而不宣，或者即使说出来了也没有人相信，再或者即使被相信了也什么都没做。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨警告的心理学：为什么有些警告会被听到，为什么许多警告会被忽视，以及做预言家所面临的陷阱。
We begin the tale of warnings made and warnings ignored in the middle of Alaska. It's a bombing day, barely jacket weather. I'm in a car riding on a weather-beaten road that leads out of Fairbanks. Chris Heimstra is driving and he points out something. You can see in the road here, you see all these bumps and all these curves. These aren't your standard potholes. The state of the road is a sign of something far more significant. Beneath the pavement, the ground is disintegrating.
我们从阿拉斯加中部开始讲述那些发出或被忽视的警告。这是一个霜冻的日子，穿夹克几乎都嫌热。我正坐在一辆车里，行驶在费尔班克斯郊外一条饱经风霜的道路上。克里斯·海姆斯特拉（Chris Heimstra）在开车，他指着某个地方说。你在这里的路面上可以看到，所有的这些颠簸和弯道。这些可不是标准的坑洼。路面的状况预示着更严重得多的问题。在路面下方，地面正在崩解。
What lies below the asphalt is the Alaskan permafrost, and it's melting. Permafrost is any soil or ice or rock that's frozen for more than two years, like two consecutive years. Picture the plants and animals that lived in Alaska over the past tens of thousands of years. After they died and fell to the ground, they froze. Pumifrost is made up of layer upon layer of this organic frozen material. There's a place where you can see what's happening deep inside this pumifrost. It's a tunnel that's hundreds of feet long.
沥青下面隐藏着阿拉斯加的永久冻土，而且它正在融化。永久冻土是指连续冻结超过两年的土壤、冰或岩石。想象一下过去几万年里生活在阿拉斯加的动植物。它们死后落在地上，便冻结起来。永久冻土就是由这种有机冷冻物质一层又一层地堆积而成的。有一个地方你可以亲眼看到永久冻土内部正发生着什么。那是一条几百英尺长的隧道。
It's built into the side of an Alaskan hill. Chris is a research scientist at the Army Corps of Engineers. He works in the cold regions, research and engineering laboratory out of Fairbanks. He has spent a lot of time in this tunnel and he's taking me there today to show me something important. There's 40,000 years of earth history that's stored and frozen in time. To get to that frozen history, we walk through a set of gates, over to a wood cabin, a whole bunch of hard hats.
它开凿在阿拉斯加的一座小山侧面。克里斯是陆军工程兵团的研究科学家。他在费尔班克斯的寒冷地区研究与工程实验室工作。他在这个隧道里度过了很多时间，今天他带我来这里是为了让我看一些重要的东西。这里储存着四万年的地球历史，并在时间中被冷冻保存。为了看到那段冷冻的历史，我们穿过几道大门，走到一个小木屋旁，那里放着一堆安全帽。
We head over to what looks like a nondescript wooden shed. It has a sign on the outside that says, US Army Corps of Engineers, and a warning to watch your step. Inside, it's pitch black. At the far end, there's another door that leads into the actual tunnel. Chris turns on the lights and leads me through. We walk down to a lower area. The deeper we go, the lower down you go into the tunnel,
我们朝一个看起来毫不起眼的木棚走去。外面挂着一个牌子，上面写着“美国陆军工程兵团”，并警告人们注意脚下。里面漆黑一片。在尽头，有另一扇通往真正隧道的门。克里斯打开灯，带我走了进去。我们往下走到一个较低的区域。我们走得越深，进入隧道的位置越低，
the older you are in sediment. The further back we move in time. Okay, so like back over here. When Chris describes what's in the tunnel, he's even toned. But what I can see all around me is completely extraordinary. So on that, that's like a 43,000 year old piece of, probably willow that's been sitting down here for quite a while. 43,000 years old. It actually looks like it could have fallen last year.
沉积物的年代就越久远。我们在时间上回溯得就越远。好吧，比如回到这边。当克里斯描述隧道里的东西时，他的语气很平静。但我周围所能看到的一切却完全非同寻常。所以那个，那是一块大约有43,000年历史的、可能是柳树的碎片，它在这里躺了相当长一段时间了。43,000年历史。它看起来其实就像是去年才掉落的一样。
Yeah it's amazing the cold temperatures and how long it can be organic matter can be preserved here. If you're picturing this like a real life trip on the magic school bus you're right except there's one part of the experience that doesn't exactly fill me with wonder. Like the aromas, one thing that people notice right away. I was just going to ask you, is it just me or does this place sting? It suddenly got it unusual smell and that's your organic matter that's coming back into the atmosphere. All around me, the decaying plants and animals smell like food gone bad in a freezer.
是的，这真是令人惊叹，寒冷的温度以及有机质在这里可以保存这么久。如果你把这想象成一次现实版的《神奇校车》之旅，那你说得对，不过体验中有一部分并不会完全让我感到惊奇。比如气味，这是人们立刻就会注意到的。我正要问你，是我一个人的错觉还是这个地方真有一股刺鼻的味道？它突然散发出一种不寻常的气味，那就是重新回到大气层中的有机质。我周围腐烂的植物和动物闻起来就像是冰箱里变质的食物。
The smell is unpleasant, but what it ought to be is terrifying. Something is happening here that has consequences for the entire planet. The organic matter trapped in the permafrost, fungi, plants, animals, it's towing. As a thaw, it decays, and as it decays, it releases extraordinary amounts of carbon into the atmosphere. How much carbon, scientists say the amount of carbon that's stored in the pomephrast, is about double of what's in the entire atmosphere. Let me say it again.
这种气味很不愉快，但它带来的感觉理应是令人恐惧的。这里正在发生的事情对整个地球都有影响。困在永久冻土中的有机物——真菌、植物、动物——正在解冻。随着解冻，它们开始腐烂，而在腐烂过程中，它们会向大气中释放惊人数量的碳。究竟有多少碳？科学家称，储存在永久冻土中的碳大约是整个大气层中碳含量的两倍。让我再说一遍。
Double. It's in the deep freeze. What happens if that temperature goes up, or for some reason it thaws a little bit more? What happens at that carbon? A place you don't necessarily want is back in the atmosphere. We don't want it back in the atmosphere,
两倍。它正处于深度冷冻状态。如果温度上升，或者由于某种原因它进一步解冻了，会发生什么？这些碳会怎么样？你绝对不想看到它们回到大气层中。我们不希望它们回到大气层中，
because carbon dioxide contributes to climate change. But a vicious cycle has already started. As the planet warms, the permafrost thaws. All those dead animals and plants and fungi start to decompose. More decomposition means more carbon released into the atmosphere, which means warmer temperatures, which means even more melting in the permafrost. What follows is disaster.
因为二氧化碳会加剧气候变化。但一个恶性循环已经开始了。随着地球变暖，永久冻土解冻。所有那些死去的动物、植物和真菌开始分解。分解加剧意味着释放到大气中的碳增多，这意味着温度更高，从而导致永久冻土进一步融化。随之而来的便是灾难。
I think the science is pretty solid to indicate that wildfire risk is likely to increase in the future due to climate change. California is marking one of the most destructive fire seasons in its history. At the rate global temperatures are rising 60% of all the glaciers here in Xinjiang, nearly 11,000 glaciers will be gone within 50 years. Chris doesn't need to turn on the news to see what rising temperatures are doing to the planet. When he's in the tunnel, he can see it right in front of his eyes. He can smell it.
我认为现有的科学证据相当充分，足以表明由于气候变化，野火风险在未来将会增加。加利福尼亚州正经历其历史上最具破坏性的火灾季节之一。按照全球气温上升的速度，新疆60%的冰川，也就是近11,000座冰川，将在50年内消失。克里斯不需要打开新闻就能看到气温上升对地球造成的影响。当他在隧道里时，他能亲眼看到这一切。他能闻到气味。
He's reminded of it every time he drives on the cracked pavement. And there's a feeling that he can't escape. It comes when he's at work, when he talks to strangers, even when he's in the comfort of his own car. That feeling is futility. He can see a catastrophe unfolding in front of him, but no one seems to be listening. Or people seem to be worried about the wrong things, like in a conversation he had earlier in the day. The claim was made that most of the CO2 in the atmosphere comes from volcanoes, which isn't the case.
每次开着车碾过裂开的路面时，他都会想起这件事。而且有一种他无法摆脱的情绪。这种感觉会在他工作时、与陌生人交谈时、甚至在自己舒服的车里时涌上心头。这种感觉就是徒劳无功。他能看到一场灾难正在眼前展开，但似乎没有人愿意倾听。或者人们似乎在担心错误的事情，就像他当天早些时候进行的一场对话一样。有人声称大气中的二氧化碳大都来自火山，事实并非如此。
Who made the claim? It was somebody on the school field trip earlier today. And I pushed back against that politely. It's hard because you got to be really It's so hard to To be you know, you don't want to offend people you don't want to because making someone angry isn't gonna change their mind at all So you got to be really careful about how you wait into things and you don't know this person Necessarily and there's not a familial tie. So it's a stranger, someone who's all we have really in common is that our kids go to the
谁提出这种说法的？那是今天早些时候参加学校郊游的一个人。我礼貌地反驳了这一点。这很难，因为你必须……这太难了……你知道的，你不想冒犯别人，你不想……因为惹恼别人根本无法改变他们的想法。所以你必须非常小心你介入的方式，而且你并不一定认识这个人，彼此之间也没有家族联系。所以他是个陌生人，我们之间唯一的共同点就是我们的孩子去
same school and they're in the same class. But it was a crucial piece of misinformation that wasn't true. And then you just say flat out, that's not true. That's going to shut everything down down and it's not going to help me in any way. It's just going to make somebody who thinks I'm a jerk. To Chris, it seems as if the pushback he gets is driven by a logic contempt that some people feel towards science and scientists. Like it's not relegated or limited to your work, it's a critique of you as a person, as if you're just trying to light up people about the work you do, which doesn't make any sense.
同一所学校，而且在同一个班级。但这却是一个至关重要的错误信息，根本不是事实。如果你直截了当地说“这不是真的”，那只会把谈话彻底聊死，对我的目的没有任何帮助。只会让别人觉得我是个混蛋。对克里斯来说，他所遭遇的反弹似乎是由某些人对科学和科学家抱有的轻蔑逻辑所驱动的。就好像这不仅限于你的工作，而是对你这个人的批判，就好像你只是想就你所从事的工作对别人指手画脚一样，这根本说不通。
Your stock as a scientist is because of your honesty, if you're not honest as a scientist, your career is over. And it should be over. Chris feels invisible. He walks in a remote place 40 feet below the surface in a part of the country that's unfamiliar to most Americans. A lot of them will never make it up here. A lot of them won't go into the Permanfrost tunnel. A lot of them won't go run up above the tunnel
作为一个科学家，你的信誉源于你的诚实；如果你作为一个科学家不够诚实，你的职业生涯就结束了。而且也理应结束。克里斯感到自己被忽视了。他在一个地表以下40英尺的偏远地方行走，这里位于美国绝大多数人都不熟悉的一个地区。他们中的很多人永远不会来到这里。他们中的很多人不会走进永久冻土隧道。他们中的很多人不会去隧道上方
or throughout Alaska where Permanfrost exists or even understand what it looks like, what it smells like. So how do you communicate that? How do you say like there's a value in you understanding what you don't currently understand? How do you get people to see that there's value in understanding what they don't understand? Chris's question is an ancient question. For millennia we often shunned and shamed people who have warned us of looming disaster. Why does this happen? Why do human beings who care about their survival ignore warnings of doom? When we come back, we are going to do something unusual.
或者阿拉斯加存在永久冻土的任何地方奔走，甚至无法理解它看起来是什么样、闻起来是什么样。那么你该如何传达这一点呢？你该如何表达，比如，去理解你目前不理解的事物是有价值的？你如何让人们看到理解他们不理解的事物是有价值的？克里斯的问题是一个古老的问题。几千年来，我们经常回避和羞辱那些警告我们迫在眉睫灾难的人。为什么会这样？为什么关心自身生存的人类会忽视厄运的警告？当我们回来时，我们将做一件不同寻常的事。
We are going to look for answers to that question, not in science, but in literature. We are going to dive into Greek mythology and talk about a doomed prophet. The lessons from her story still resonate today. In Greek mythology, the gods loom large, so large that many of them fill our imaginations even today, Zeus with his thunderbolts, Aphrodite the goddess of love, Hades in charge of the underworld, Athena goddess of wisdom. The gods of ancient Greece moved among humans, Some of those humans were themselves touched with divine powers. One of the most striking was the Prophet Cassandra. Cassandra remained so memorable that her
我们将从文学而不是科学中寻找这个问题的答案。我们将深入探讨希腊神话，谈谈一位注定悲剧的女先知。她故事中的教训在今天依然引起共鸣。在希腊神话中，众神高大威严，以至于他们中的许多人至今仍占据着我们的想象力：手持雷霆的宙斯、爱神阿佛洛狄忒、掌管冥界的哈迪斯、智慧女神雅典娜。古希腊的众神在人类中穿行，其中一些人自身也被赋予了神圣的力量。最引人注目的一位就是女先知卡珊德拉（Cassandra）。卡珊德拉令人难以忘怀，以至于她的
story has inspired movies, television, even campy pop music. No one believed you. In 1982, the Swedish band Abba dedicated a song to her more than 2,500 years after she was first memorialized by Homer, Eskilis and Euripides. This power that Cassandra had was incredible. Except, there was one problem. No one believed her. It's not Cassandra's fault that she's not believed. This is Emily Wilson.
故事激发了电影、电视甚至媚俗流行音乐的灵感。没有人相信你。1982年，瑞典乐队ABBA在一首歌曲中献给她，此时距离她首次被荷马、埃斯库罗斯和欧里庇得斯写入史诗已经过去了2500多年。卡珊德拉拥有的这种力量太不可思议了。除了一个问题。没有人相信她。不被相信并不是卡珊德拉的错。这是埃米利·威尔逊（Emily Wilson）。
I'm a professor of classical studies at the University of Pennsylvania. Emily is going to take us back to the legend of the Kingdom of Troy. She's going to help us understand what this ancient myth still has to teach us. Cassandra's father, Pryam, was the king of Troy. It's safe to say that Cassandra didn't suffer from only child syndrome. Pryam has, according to different accounts, either 50 or 100 children. She's one of the many children of Pryam. Cassandra has a blessing that is really a curse.
我是宾夕法尼亚大学古典文学研究教授。埃米利将带我们回到特洛伊王国的传说中。她将帮助我们理解这个古老的神话至今仍能教给我们什么。卡珊德拉的父亲普里阿摩斯（Priam）是特洛伊国王。可以肯定地说，卡珊德拉并没有患上独生子女综合征。根据不同的记载，普里阿摩斯有50个或100个孩子。她是普里阿摩斯的众多孩子之一。卡珊德拉得到了一种其实是诅咒的祝福。
She can see the future, but no one will believe her. But even if you set aside the curse, it turns out she also did several things that made it less likely she would be believed. For one thing, her prophecies were opaque. When she revealed her visions, she spoke in language that was a little hard to understand. Let the mob endlessly gorging on this clan, raise a shriek over the sacrifice on which stones will fall in their turn.
她能预见未来，但没有人会相信她。但即便抛开这个诅咒不谈，事实证明她还做过几件让人更不可能相信她的事。首先，她的预言含糊不清。当她透露自己的预言时，她使用的语言有点难以理解。让暴徒在这个宗族里无休止地饕餮，为献祭发出尖叫吧，一块块石头也将轮流砸落。
She speaks primarily in symbols and metaphors that she can foresee the ox killed at the altar. She can foresee blood and slaughter. She doesn't speak in a way that spells out exactly as soon as I walk into this house, Clayton Nesteros is going to take the axe and hack us both to death. Because that's not the way oracles speak. She speaks in prophetic language. Cassandra's best known prophecy had to do with one of the world's most famous carpentry projects, the Trojan horse. There's a war between the Trojans and the Greeks and it's dragging on.
她主要用符号和隐喻来发言，她能预见祭坛前被杀的公牛。她能预见血腥与屠杀。她说话的方式不是那种直白的——“我一走进这栋房子，克吕泰涅斯特拉就会拿起斧头把我们两个活活砍死”。因为神谕从不这样说话。她使用的是预言的语言。卡珊德拉最著名的预言与世界上最著名的木工项目之一——特洛伊木马有关。特洛伊人和希腊人之间爆发了一场战争，并且旷日持久。
It keeps going for 10 years without decisive victory on either side. The turning point comes when the Greeks have an idea. That they should build a great big wooden horse and have their best warriors on the Greek side hide inside the wooden horse. They leave the great big wooden horse outside the walls of Troy. As the Trojans watch from their city, the Greeks get in their ships, seemingly in defeat, and sail away. Their mysterious gift remains on the beach, and the Trojan's debate, whether to throw open the city gates, and bring in the horse. Is this some kind of gift for the gods? Is it a holy offering? Should be mistrusted? Should we not mistrusted? Cassandra knows that this gift is not a gift at all.
战争持续了10年，双方都没有取得决定性的胜负。转折点出现在希腊人想出一个主意。他们应该建造一只巨大的木马，并让希腊阵营中最优秀的勇士藏在木马内部。他们把这只巨大的木马留在了特洛伊城墙外。当特洛伊人在城里观望时，希腊人登上战船，假装战败并扬帆远航。他们神秘的礼物留在了海滩上，特洛伊人开始争论，是否应该敞开城门把木马拉进来。这究竟是献给神明的某种礼物吗？这是一件神圣的祭品吗？我们应该对它起疑心吗？我们不该起疑心吗？卡珊德拉知道这根本不是什么礼物。
She tells her fellow citizens not to open the gates of Troy. In her own convoluted way, she says, this is a terrible idea. Don't do it. But she doesn't have any real power. Her fellow childrens don't recognize her as a prophet. And so she's not taken seriously. The consequences are disastrous. The Trojans decide in the end to bring the horse in, and then of course in the middle of
她告诉同胞们不要打开特洛伊城门。她用自己那种令人费解的方式说，这绝对是个烂主意。千万别这么做。但她没有任何真正的权力。她的同胞并不承认她是个先知。因此她没有被认真对待。后果是灾难性的。特洛伊人最终决定把木马拉进城内，当然，随后在半夜里，
the night the Greek warriors spring out of the horse and start slaughtering the citizens inside the city. You think that after Cassandra accurately predicts the fall of Troy, some people might start believing her. You'd be wrong. She makes another prediction that fails to gain any traction. As the city is burning and the women of Troy are forced to board Greek ships as slaves, all the prisoners are distraught, all except Cassandra, who seems weirdly happy.
希腊勇士从木马中跃出，开始屠杀城内的居民。你以为在卡珊德拉准确预测了特洛伊的陷落之后，有些人可能会开始相信她。那你就大错特错了。她又做出了另一个没有引起任何反响的预言。当城市在燃烧、特洛伊的妇女们被迫作为奴隶登上希腊战船时，所有的囚犯都心烦意乱，唯独卡珊德拉看起来诡异地快乐。
Her mother seems deeply concerned about her worried for her as one would be for a daughter who keeps saying crazy stuff, and who also seems to have this perverse idea that being taken into slavery could be a good thing. There's a reason why Cassandra has this oddly positive reaction. Whereas everyone else can only see what's right in front of them, she can see two steps ahead. She already knows something about her situation. She knows she's going to die, but so is her captor, the Greek general Agamemnon. Revenge is coming, even if it means her own death. Cassandra sees a gleam of hope in the fact that she knows Agamemnon
她的母亲似乎对她深感担忧，为她感到忧心忡忡，正如人们对一个总是说胡话、而且似乎有一种变态想法认为沦为奴隶可能是件好事的女儿所感到的那样。卡珊德拉之所以有这种奇怪的积极反应是有原因的。当其他人只能看到眼前的事物时，她能提前看到两步。她已经对自己的处境有所了解。她知道自己会死，但她的俘虏、希腊将军阿伽门农（Agamemnon）也会死。复仇即将来临，哪怕这意味着她自己的死亡。卡珊德拉从阿伽门农将要
is going to be murdered horribly. She can see that there's going to be bad things for the Greeks down the line. So to recap, there are several things, besides the curse, that make Cassandra less likely to be believed. She speaks in cryptic language. She doesn't have any formal authority. She's too far ahead of everyone else. There's one more thing. She asks too much of the people she warns. This happens when Agamemnon takes Cassandra back to Greece with him as a slave. They go to his home. Agamemnon doesn't know that during his absence, his wife, Clitam Nestra, has started an affair. He doesn't know that Clitam Nestra is not pleased to have him back, but she pretends to be happy.
被残忍谋杀的事实中看到了一丝希望之光。她能预见到希腊人在未来会有不好的下场。总而言之，除了诅咒之外，还有几个原因让卡珊德拉更不被信任。她使用隐秘的语言。她没有任何正式权威。她比所有人都看得太远。还有最后一件事。她对她所警告的人要求太多了。当阿伽门农带着卡珊德拉作为奴隶回到希腊时，这种情况就发生了。他们去了他的家。阿伽门农并不知道，在他缺席期间，他的妻子克吕泰涅斯特拉（Clytemnestra）已经有了外遇。他不知道克吕泰涅斯特拉并不高兴看到他回来，但她假装很高兴。
So she welcomes him into the house, along with Cassandra, as his human property. He goes first into the house and then Cassandra pauses to give these prophecies, these riddling prophecies. Cassandra foresees his death and her own. Look at this. Look. Keep the bull away from the heifer. She's caught him in her dress, her engine on her black horn, striking!
于是她迎他进屋，连同卡珊德拉——他的战利品一起。他先进了屋，然后卡珊德拉停下来开始发表这些预言，这些谜语般的预言。卡珊德拉预见了他和她自己的死。看这个！看。让公牛远离小母牛！她用她的长袍缠住了他，用黑角的机关，击打！
Into the basin, he falls, with the water lies. He met his death in the bath. It's lay and wait for him, I tell you. Or, to translate, Clayton Nestres is about to hack her husband to death with an axe. For Agamemnon to take a Sandra seriously, he would have to see that his life was in danger, that his wife despised him, that far from being a victorious warrior, he was walking into a death trap. To save his own life,
他落入盆中，伴随着积水。他在浴池里迎来了死亡。我告诉你，这是为他设下的陷阱。或者，翻译一下，克吕泰涅斯特拉正准备用斧头把她的丈夫活活砍死。要想让阿伽门农认真对待卡珊德拉，他就必须看到自己的生命正处于危险之中，看到他的妻子鄙视他，看到自己非但不是一个凯旋的勇士，反而是走入了一个死亡陷阱。为了挽救自己的生命，
he would have to change his entire outlook. He wants to think of himself as a strong triumphant city saccer, and he's only going to process the information that confirms that belief about himself. And he's going to ignore all the signs both from Clyde Nester and from Cassandra that might suggest that reality is not the only reality, and in fact, you're missing a whole lot of information here.
他必须改变自己全部的看法。他希望把自己想象成一个强大而凯旋的破城者，他只会处理那些证实他对自己这种看法的信念的信息。而他会忽略所有来自克吕泰涅斯特拉和卡珊德拉的迹象，这些迹象可能暗示现实并非唯一的现实，事实上，你漏掉了大量的信息。
Things play out just as Cassandra predicted. She's caught him in her dress, her engine, on her black horn, striking. Clotum Leastra gives him a lovely bath and she entrap him in a net as well in order to make sure that if he struggles after the first blow, he won't get away. So she strikes him multiple times till he's good and dead, and also hats Cassandra to death.
事情的发展正如卡珊德拉所预测的那样。她用长袍缠住了他，用黑角的机关，击打。克吕泰涅斯特拉为他洗了个舒服澡，她还用一张网把他网住，以确保他在遭受第一击后如果挣扎也逃不脱。于是她连击他多下直到他死透，顺便也把卡珊德拉给砍死了。
The soundtrack was a particularly gruesome murder, but maybe I'm wrong, maybe this is part for the course in Athenian tragedy. I think it's part for the course, I mean it's much less gruesome than the death of Pentheus, say yes. That was usually some gory death, yeah. Why else would you go to the theatre? Now of course, Cassandra was cursed. By definition, it didn't matter how persuasive she was.
刚才的音轨是一场特别可怕的谋杀，但也许我错了，也许这在雅典悲剧中只是家常便饭。我认为这就是家常便饭，我是说，这比彭透斯（Pentheus）的死要温和得多，没错。那通常是相当血腥的死亡，是的。不然你为什么要去剧院呢？当然，卡珊德拉受到了诅咒。按定义来说，无论她多么有说服力，
She was never going to be believed. But her failed attempts to warn those around her can give us insights into how warnings are heard, whether they take it seriously, and when they're acted upon. When we come back, how can real life Cassandra's undo the curse and actually be believed? This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is what a Cassandra who's effective sounds like. I speak loudly all the time, because I'm kind of aggressive person, you know, even though I'm all I'll be 70 next year. My wife said, will you please calm down?
人们永远都不会相信她。但她警告周围人的那些失败尝试，可以让我们深入了解警告是如何被倾听的、人们是否会认真对待以及何时会采取行动。当我们回来时，现实生活中的“卡珊德拉”们如何才能解除诅咒并真正被人信任？这里是《隐藏的大 脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这就是一个高效的“卡珊德拉”听起来的样子。我一直都大声说话，因为我有点好斗，你知道的，尽管我明年就70岁了。我妻子说：“你能不能冷静点？”
She's been saying it for 43 years now and it hasn't happened. The actual name of this Cassandra is Andrew Nazios. His moment of prophecy involved a life and death choice that affected hundreds of thousands of people. Before we get to that, we need to understand the formative moments in Andrew's career. In many ways, he was an unlikely hero. In the 1980s, he served in the Massachusetts House of Representatives. At a Republican National Committee meeting in 1988, he didn't exactly get the star treatment. Chair recognizes Nassio from Maryland. Nassio's from Massachusetts.
她这样说了43年了，但情况并无改变。这位“卡珊德拉”的真名叫安德鲁·纳齐奥斯（Andrew Natsios）。他展现先知之见的时刻涉及一个生死抉择，影响了数十万人。在我们谈到这一点之前，我们需要了解安德鲁职业生涯中的成长关键期。在很多方面，他都不是那种传统的英雄。在20世纪80年代，他曾在马萨诸塞州众议院任职。在1988年的一次共和党全国委员会会议上，他并没有得到什么明星待遇。主席承认马里兰州的纳齐奥斯。马萨诸塞州的纳齐奥斯。
Nassio's, I'm so quarantined here, sorry. Before he got to Esquisandra moment, Andrew was brought into salvage a boondoggle of a transportation project in Boston. The big dick. It redirected a massive highway into a tunnel under the city. Andrew came in several years into the project. At that point, it was a mess with huge cost overruns. Andrew had two things going for him.
纳齐奥斯，我在这里被隔离了，抱歉。在迎来他的“卡珊德拉”时刻之前，安德鲁被请去挽救波士顿一个糟糕透顶的交通项目。“大挖沟”（The Big Dig）。它将一条大型高速公路改道引入城市下方的隧道中。安德鲁在该项目开始几年后接手。当时，该项目是一团乱麻，严重超支。安德鲁有两个优势。
He had experienced leading big institutions. And he had his temperament. I'm sort of a type A personality very kind of aggressive and a dominant figure in any institution that I run. So I could get the institution to do what I wanted it to do what I thought was right to do. He was in fact able to figure out why the project's finances were out of whack, but his efforts weren't always appreciated it was the most difficult year of my career actually
他有领导大型机构的经验。而且他有他的脾气。我有点A型人格，非常咄咄逼人，在我运营的任何机构中都是一个占主导地位的人物。所以我能让机构按照我的意愿行事，按照我认为正确的方式行事。他的确查明了该项目财务混乱的原因，但他的努力并不总是受到赞赏，这其实是我职业生涯中最艰难的一年。
i actually felt safer in so then and iraq and afghanistan that i did in boston uh... one person threatened to break my neck well i was investigating the big digg and uh... i was threatened once i took over too, so I'm going to threaten to kill me then too. That did not happen in Sudan. Andrew had spent much of his career overseas.
在波士顿的经历甚至让我觉得比在伊拉克和阿富汗还要安全。有个人威胁要拧断我的脖子，当时我正在调查“大挖沟”，而且……自我接手后我也受到过威胁，当时也有人威胁要杀我。那在苏丹可没发生过。安德鲁的大部分职业生涯都是在海外度过的。
His experience leading several national and international organizations, Cothea of President George W. Bush, who appointed him to lead USAID. That's the agency responsible for America's involvement in international development. It's here that Andrew had his prophetic moment. In 2003, Andrew briefed top members of the Bush administration about escalating violence in Sudan. By that point, marauders were charging into villages, setting them on fire, sending civilians fleeing. They were known as a janguete.
他领导多个国家和国际组织的经历，引起了小布什总统的注意，后者任命他领导美国国际开发署（USAID）。该机构负责美国对国际发展的参与。正是在这里，安德鲁迎来了他的先知时刻。2003年，安德鲁向布什政府高层官员简要汇报了苏丹不断升级的暴力冲突。当时，暴徒冲入村庄，放火焚烧，迫使平民逃亡。他们被称为“金戈威德”（Janjaweed）。
They quickly took over a vast and dusty region on the edge of the Sahara. Darfur. Andrew's warnings and advice had an impact. The US supplied billions of dollars in aid to Sudan over the next several years. Inspired the economic difficulties, our aid will continue to flow. the next several years. President Bush also put political pressure on Sudanese leaders. Some of his measures were behind the scenes, others more public. The news media began to take note.
他们迅速占领了撒哈拉边缘一片广阔而尘土飞扬的地区——达尔富尔。安德鲁的警告和建议产生了影响。在接下来的几年里，美国向苏丹提供了数十亿美元的援助。尽管面临经济困难，我们的援助仍将继续流出。在接下来的几年里。布什总统还对苏丹领导人施加了政治压力。他的部分举措是在幕后进行的，另一些则更加公开。新闻媒体开始注意到这一点。
Today President Bush announced tough new economic sanctions against Sudan over the continued persecution of the minority population in Darfur. Andrews actions at USAID have become a case study on effective warnings. That's according to Christoph Mayer. I'm a professor of European and international politics at King's College, London. Christoph has spent many years studying how warnings are made and which ones manage to break through the noise. He says there are several reasons Andrew Nio's managed to persuade the Bush Administration to act.
今天，布什总统宣布对苏丹实施严厉的新经济制裁，起因是其持续迫害达尔富尔的少数族裔人口。安德鲁在美国国际开发署的行动已成为有效警告的案例研究。克里斯托夫·迈尔（Christoph Meyer）如是说。我是伦敦国王学院欧洲与国际政治教授。克里斯托夫花了很多年时间研究警告是如何发出的，以及哪些警告能够穿透噪音脱颖而出。他说，安德鲁·纳齐奥斯之所以能说服布什政府采取行动，有几个原因。
One is he was able to show how further escalation with many hundreds of thousands of people that was highly likely and he was able to kind of put that into a presentation, you know, chart the escalation of the conflict into the future. Andrew commissioned a study that predicted how many people would die if the US didn't intervene. He also got US spy satellites to take pictures of Darfur. To photograph the ground every day to show the villages that were being burned from day to day. And these photographs were so clear that the photographs were unimpeachable in terms of their quality, in terms of what the atrocities were. They burned 30 at
一是，他能够展示冲突进一步升级将波及数十万人的情况，这极有可能发生，而且他能够将这一点制作成演示文稿，绘制冲突在未来升级的图表。安德鲁委托进行了一项研究，预测如果美国不进行干预会有多少人死亡。他还让美国间谍卫星拍摄达尔富尔的照片。每天拍摄地面照片，展示那些被一天天烧毁的村庄。这些照片非常清晰，在质量以及暴行真相方面无可辩驳。他们烧毁了30个
Henry Villages. They displaced two million people. So Andrew laid out clear evidence. There was something else that helped him make the case to the president. He was an insider. Was I taken seriously yes because I had a relationship with the president? That's presidents plural. He had campaigned twice for George H. W. Bush and he had worked on the George W. Bush campaign in 2000. He was not seen as one of these, you know, do good as one, one of these liberal NGO types.
亨利村庄。他们导致两百万流离失所。所以安德鲁列出了清晰的证据。还有一件事帮助他说服了总统。他是个内圈人。我被认真对待了吗？是的，因为我与总统有联系。那是复数的“总统”。他曾两次为老布什的竞选活动奔走，并参与了2000年小布什的竞选工作。他不被看作是那种……你知道的，行善者，那种自由派非政府组织的人。
Yes, he had a history in the NGO sector, he was an expert, but he had also a conservative pedigree, he had experience in the armed forces. He was seen as someone who understood that the president's time was precious and understood the preferences, and he was seen as part of us. And therefore, if someone who was seen as a
是的，他在非政府组织领域有背景，他是一个专家，但他也有保守派血统，他有军队经验。人们认为他是一个理解总统时间宝贵、了解总统偏好的人，他被视为我们自己人。因此，如果一个被视为几乎具有国家安全背景的人，如果这样一个人警告那种国家的那种冲突后果，他受到的重视程度要远高于那些被以完全不同眼光看待的人。除了政治资历外，安德鲁在另一个层面上也是个圈内人。他是一名基督徒，曾领导一个国际基督教非政府组织多年。他知道小布什总统的基督徒身份对他很重要，对其在2004年的连任竞选也很重要。克里斯托夫·迈尔表示，安德鲁阐明了对达尔富尔不采取行动的政治后果，因为那里许多遭受袭击的平民
kind of someone who is kind of almost a national security type, if someone like that would warn about the consequences of that kind of conflict in that country, he would be taking so much more seriously than someone who is seen in a very different light. Besides his political credentials, Andrew was also an insider in another way. He was a Christian who'd spent years leading an international Christian NGO. He knew that George W. Bush's identity as a Christian was important to him and important to his re-election chances in 2004. Christoph Mayer says Andrew laid out the political consequences of inaction in Darfur, where many of the civilians being attacked
都是基督徒。他随后能够展示这种升级在当时对布什政府具有怎样的政治相关性，它将如何影响连任几率，以及它将如何与美国的基督教选民群体产生联系——当然，基督教选民群体是布什政府的支持选民之一，因为受这场暴力冲突影响最大的人群很大程度上也正是苏丹的基督徒。安德鲁潜意识里理解一种普遍存在的心理偏差。当受苦的人与我们有某些共同点时，我们往往会对其苦难表现出更多同情。
were Christian. He was able then to show how that kind of escalation would be politically relevant to the Bush administration at the time, how it would impact on the re-election chances, and how it would connect to Christian constituency in the US, which of course are one of the supporting constituencies of the Bush administration, because it was also Christians who were in Sudan were largely affected by this violence. Andrew implicitly understood a widespread psychological bias. We all tend to look more sympathetically at suffering when the people who are suffering
这还有另一个层面。安德鲁之所以成功，是因为他没有要求布什总统做出重大的一百八十度大转弯。从其执政一开始，总统就对苏丹发生的事情很感兴趣。总统下令进行的第一次总统审视就是针对苏丹政策的。现在，达尔富尔后来被称为种族灭绝的灾难确实夺去了数十万人的生命，所以把安德鲁的警告看作是有效的可能会有些困难。
have something in common with us. There's another part to this. Andrew was successful because he didn't ask President Bush to make a major U-turn. From the very beginning of his administration, the president had been interested in what was happening and so done. The first presidential review that the president ordered was on Sudan policy. Now, what came to be known as a genocide in Darfur did claim hundreds of thousands of lives, so it may be hard to see Andrews warning as effective.
然而，克里斯托夫认为，如果安德鲁没有采取行动，事情的结局会更糟。我认为布什政府确实采取了行动，它采取行动非常早，但它在政治上采取行动对冲突各方施加了压力，而且我认为他们在人道主义方面采取了尽可能早的行动，从而通过人道主义行动拯救了生命。我本无法独自做到这一点，但布什总统做到了，我不得不说，我在书中写过，我认为他终结了另一场可能发生的卢旺达大屠杀。因此，在安德鲁·纳齐奥斯身上，我们看到了一个直言不讳的领导者。
And yet, if Andrew had not acted, Christophe says he believes things would have turned out worse. I think the Bush administration did act, it did act very early, but it did act politically to put pressure on the conflict parties and they did act, I think, as soon as could be probably expected on the humanitarian front, therefore saving lives through humanitarian action. I couldn't have done that alone, but President Bush did it, and I have to say I said in my book, I think he ended what could have been another Rwanda genocide. So in Andrew Nazios, we have a plain spoken leader.
他拥有让其他人加入进来的内部资历，而且他没有要求决策者去做那些与他们原本就想做的事情大相径庭的事。相比之下，还记得我们之前听到的那个注定悲剧的先知吗？卡珊德拉，说着谜语，预言的谜语，但终究是谜语。让暴徒在这个宗族里无休止地饕餮。为献祭发出尖叫吧，一块块石头也将轮流砸落。与安德鲁·纳齐奥斯不同，卡珊德拉不是个圈内人。
He had the insider credentials to get others on board, and he didn't ask policy makers to do something that was greatly at odds with what they wanted to do anyway. Contrast that with the doomed prophet we heard about earlier. Cassandra, spoken riddles, prophetic riddles, but riddles nonetheless. Let the mob endlessly gorging on this clan. Raise a shriek over the sacrifice on which stones will fall in their turn. Unlike Andrew Natios, Cassandra wasn't an insider.
正如埃米利·威尔逊所说，卡珊德拉比所有人都走得太远了。当她和其他妇女儿童被当作奴隶俘虏时，她并没有解释自己高兴是因为她知道希腊人将被杀死。她能预见未来，但她没有把其他人一起带上。这为我们的时代提供了教训。克里斯托夫说，许多现代的“卡珊德拉”忘记了，对大多数人来说，要长远展望未来是很难的。领导者尤其往往被拉向不同的方向。关注一个风险
As Emily Wilson says, and Cassandra was too far ahead of everyone else. When she and the other children women are being captured as slaves, she doesn't explain that she is happy because she knows the Greeks are going to be killed. She can see into the future, but she doesn't take others along with her. There are lessons here for our own time. Kristoff says many modern Cassandra's forget its hard for most people to look far into the future. Leaders especially are often pulled in different directions. Paying attention to one risk
就意味着分配给其他风险的资源减少。如果你带着对一个遥远问题的模糊警告出现，你就会被边缘化。萨曼莎·鲍尔（Samantha Power）在一本书《来自地狱的问题》中写道，一位行政官员对给出的警告的反应是：除非他的电话铃响个不停，否则他什么也做不了。因此，即使他相信她说的是对的，他也受到缺乏华盛顿政治圈中大声疾呼的公众支持采取行动的限制，以至于他什么也做不到。卡珊德拉还要求她试图警告的人们
means fewer resources for others. If you come in with a vague warning about a distant problem, you're going to get sidelined. Samantha Powell wrote in a book, a problem from hell, about the response from one administrator to the warning that that was given, that unless his telephones were ringing, he couldn't do anything. So even if he believed that what she was saying is right, he was so constrained by the lack of incensed public clamoring in the beltway that comes support for acting that he couldn't do something. Cassandra also asked the people she was trying to warn, to stretch too far outside their comfort the comfort for acting that he couldn't do something.
跨出他们的舒适区太远。还记得当克吕泰涅斯特拉给阿伽门农一个舒服的澡时发生了什么吗？在她把他活活砍死之前？卡珊德拉预见到了这一点。看这个！看！让公牛远离小母牛！
Cassandra also asked the people she was trying to warn to stretch too far outside their comfort zone. Remember what Clitam Nestra is giving Agamemnon a lovely bath? Before she hacks him to death? Cassandra saw it coming. Look at this! Look! Keep the bull away from the heifer!
但阿伽门农的心态根本无法听进这个警告。克里斯托夫说，这在现实生活中的“卡珊德拉”和现实生活中的决策者身上都会发生。如果领导者必须拒绝某些基础信念才能根据警告采取行动，那么他们很有可能会直接忽视这个警告。通常情况下，让警告如此难以置信的原因在于它们在政治上很不方便。事实上，这正是挑战者号航天飞机灾难中发生的情况。一项科学调查发现，几位工程师曾对后来被称为航天飞机“O形环”的安全问题表示担忧。
But Agamemnon wasn't in a headspace where he could hear the warning. Christophe says this happens with real-life Cassandra's and real-life policy makers. If leaders have to reject some foundational belief to act on a warning, there's a strong chance that they will simply ignore the warning. Quite often, what makes warnings so difficult to believe is that they are politically inconvenience. In fact, this is exactly what happened in the case of the Challenger Space Shuttle disaster. A scientific inquiry found that several engineers had had concerns about the safety of what came to be known as the O-rings on the shuttle.
但阿伽门农当时的心态根本听不进去这个警告。克里斯托夫表示，现实中的卡珊德拉和现实中的决策者之间也常常发生这种情况。如果领导者必须否定某种基础信念才能对警告采取行动，那么他们极有可能会直接忽视这个警告。通常情况下，警告之所以很难让人相信，是因为它们在政治上很不方便。事实上，挑战者号航天飞机灾难事件中发生的正是这种情况。一项科学调查发现，几位工程师曾对后来被称为航天飞机O形环的安全性产生过担忧。
They told NASA managers to delay the launch, but the managers overruled the engineers and the challenger took off his plan. We've painted a picture of warnings that is at odds with the way most of us think about them. We've painted a picture of warnings that is at odds with the way most of us think about them. In the conventional telling, someone raises an alarm and everyone jumps up and does something about it. In reality, warnings are likely to be heard when they're made by someone who's part of our in-group, when the warning is so imminent that nearly everyone can see the danger, and when the solution doesn't require a radical shift in existing strategy.
他们告诉美国宇航局管理者推迟发射，但管理者推翻了工程师的意见，挑战者号按计划升空了。我们描绘的关于警告的图景与我们大多数人对它的看法大相径庭。我们描绘的关于警告的图景与我们大多数人对它的看法大相径庭。在传统的故事中，某人发出警报，每个人都跳起来并采取行动。实际上，当警告由属于我们内群体的人发出、当警告迫在眉睫以至于几乎所有人都能看到危险、以及当解决方案不需要对现有战略进行激进转变时，警告才最有可能被倾听。
Unsurprisingly, this means that many warnings will go unheeded, and many Cassandra's will be dismissed. In Greek mythology, Cassandra was cursed to be ignored. There really wasn't anything she could do to get people to believe her. For the Cassandra's in our own midst, the curse is even more terrible. Fast sets of the human mind make it difficult for us to pay attention to warnings and difficult to act on them until it's nearly too late. How do we make sure that this kind of breach?
毫无疑问，这意味着许多警告将石沉大海，许多“卡珊德拉”将被解雇。在希腊神话中，卡珊德拉被诅咒无人相信。她确实无能为力让人相信她。对于我们身边的“卡珊德拉”们来说，这个诅咒更加可怕。人类心智的固有特征使我们难以关注警告，也难以在为时已晚之前采取行动。我们如何确保这种违规行为？
That such an accident never happens again. This week's episode was produced by Raina Cohen with help from Thomas Liu. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Jennifer Schmidt. Our team includes Parth Shah, Laura Quarell and Kimela Vargas Restrepo. Our runs on Hero this Week is Sophia Dawkins. Sophia has spent years studying the conflict in South Sudan. She patiently helped us understand the complicated history of the region to get the nuances right.
确保这样的事故永远不再发生。本周的节目由雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）制作，托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）协助。由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和詹妮弗·施密特（Jennifer Schmidt）剪辑。我们的团队包括帕思·沙阿（Parth Shah）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）和基梅拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波（Kimela Vargas Restrepo）。本周的片尾曲制作人是索菲亚·道金斯（Sophia Dawkins）。索菲亚多年来一直在研究南苏丹的冲突。她耐心地帮助我们理解该地区复杂的历史，以确保细节的准确性。
Sometimes, the most important contribution someone can make to a story is to get things out of the story. Thank you, Sophia. You can find more hidden Brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you like the show, please tell one friend today about our program. I know from both my personal experience and the social science literature
有时候，一个人对一个故事最重要的贡献，就是删掉故事里的一些内容。谢谢你，索菲亚。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到更多Hidden Brain的内容。如果你喜欢这个节目，今天请向一位朋友推荐我们的节目。我从个人经历和 社会科学文献中了解到
that word-of-mouth recommendations really matter. If you love Hidden Brain, please spread the word. One last thing before we go, and we save this until the end for a reason. If you've stuck with us all the way through our credits, you may be a superfan. If you're someone who rarely misses an episode, who tells friends and co-workers about our show and would like to connect more deeply with us, we want your help and understanding how to make hidden brain more relevant and more useful to you.
口碑推荐确实非常重要。如果你喜欢Hidden Brain，请帮忙宣传一下。在我们离开之前还有最后一件事，我们把这个留在最后是有原因的。如果你一直听到了片尾字幕结束，那你可能就是一个超级粉丝。如果你是一个很少错过任何一期节目、会向朋友和同事介绍我们的节目、并希望与我们建立更深联系的人，我们需要你的帮助，来了解如何让Hidden Brain与你更相关、对你更有用。
Please send us an email at hiddenbrainatnpr.org with a subject line, superfan and a phone number. Again, that's hiddenbrainatnpr.org. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR. VR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请给我们发送电子邮件至hiddenbrainatnpr.org，主题写上“超级粉丝”并附上电话号码。再次强调，邮箱是hiddenbrainatnpr.org。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。